I'll start at the beginning my whole  family was killed in a car accident  someone did horrific experiments on me I  was abducted raped and forced to kill  someone and I'm in here bouncing so how  was anger-management still angry some  people call me a hero  others call me a freak you're one of  them [ __ ] I didn't ask for this I'm  just trying to make a goddamn living in  this goddamn City you API I'm  resourceful people I care about are in  danger I gotta make a decision one keep  denying it for to do something about it  we belong way down below  [Music]  anyway I know it's called whiskey  [ __ ] call me a [ __ ] again Jessica  Jones you are a hard-drinking  short-fused mess  anything bad Miss Jones  yeah I always see what threats head-on  meaning I punch them in the head until  they're unconscious  [Music]  you